وبعيدا عن دراما رمضان هناك دراما ماليه
يجب الحديث حول فكما يبدو ان شهر رمضان
شهر الخير والعطاء قد يستغل البعض للقيام
بعمليات نصف الكتروني الخبراء يحذرون من
اساليب الاحتيال المختلفه الاحصائيات تكشف
ان حجم الاحتيال في العالم وصل في 2021
الى اكثر من سته تريليونان دولار والرقم
مرشح للزياده سنويا وبحسب احصائيه لشركه
سايبر سكيورتيز الامريكيه من المتوقع ان
تصل الخسائر جراء عمليات الاحتيال خلال
عام 2022 الى اكثر من ثمانيه تريليونات
دولار في جميع انحاء العالم
تنامي ظاهره الاحتيال الرقمي في الشهر
المبارك يعني لماذا يعني عصابات الكترونيه
تزيد من الايقاع بالضحايا في هذا الشهر
الفضيل
اول شيء مع زياده الامان اللي موجوده سواء
في البنوك او في المنصات تواصل اجتماعيه
او غيرها اتجه المحتالون لاستخدام طرق
الهندسه الاجتماعيه في الاحتيال على
المستخدمين وسرقه عمان فهم يستهدفون فتره
شهر رمضان المبارك لسبب واحد انه يزود
الطلب على اغلب الشغلات في هذا الشهر
فالناس تقدر تتسوق من المواقع الالكترونيه
وتحتاج مثلا عماله منزليه قبل رمضان على
اساس تساعدهم في المنزل فتره رمضان فهم
يبدون يطورون مهاراتهم في عمليات الاحتيال
يمكن ابشع شيء انا شفته في طرق الاحتيال
اللي موجوده عمليات الاحتيال لسرقه
المعتمرين او الحجاج تخيل انك انت لو حابب
تحجز مثلا فنادق في مكه في مواقع احتياليه
موجوده تسرق فلوسك عن طريق هذا الطريق او
مثلا عن طريق الاحتيال من خلال حجوزات
القطارات او حجوزات النقل المختلفه طبعا
المحتالين يسوون طرق صراحه مختلفه سواء عن
طريق تزييف المواقع الالكترونيه او انتحال
صفه موقع الكترونيه مختلفه فعلى سبيل
المثال في متاجر الكترونيه مشهوره احنا
عارفينها تكثر نشاطها في رمضان في شركات
للعماله المنزليه يكثر نشاطا في رمضان
يكون عندهم عروض مميزه لرمضان التعليل
يبدون يسوون مواقع الكترونيه تنتحل نفس
الصفه تدخل على الموقع نفسه تلقى انهم
ماخذين نفس الشكل نفس كل شيء مجرد انك ما
تدخل وتطلب مثلا الخدمه او تطلب العرض او
تحجز لك رحله في القطار وغيرها هم ياخذون
بيانات البطاقه حقتك يشربون الاموال اللي
موجوده داخل البطاقه طبعا كيف تضمن وتتاكد
من الموقع اللي انت داخل عليه لازم تحرص
ان الموقع يكون موقع كامل ما تلقى قدامه
خدمه او سايت جوجل او غيرها مع العلم
للاسف المحتالين حاليا يشترون نتائج البحث
اللي موجوده في جوجل فلو دخلت حاليا في
جوجل لو انت موجود في السعوديه وكتبتها
مثلا عروض عماله منزليه تقريبا
او من هي مواقع رسميه لذلك هم يشترون
الاعلانات في جوجل ايضا يشترون الاعلانات
في بعض منص
ات وهنا رساله لازم نوجهها لل
ناس هو الاعلان يظهر لك اذا كان بدايته
جوجل او خدمه ويكس او غيرها من المواقع
هذه هذه دائما تكون عمليات احتياليه